حرب عالميه على التطبيق الصيني الاشهر
تحركات واسعه من الحكومات في جميع المناطق
لحظر او تقييد تيك توك في ظل مخاوف امنيه
متزايده البيع او الحظر بهذه الطريقه
تواصل واشنطن الضغط
الولايات المتحده تدفع المالكين الصينيين
للتخلي عن الشركه وان لم يحدث فان الحظر
سيكون مصيرا المنصه في الولايات المتحده
تقول اداره بعيدا الحمله الامريكيه تعتبر
ان تيك توك يمنح السلطات الصينيه امكانيه
الوصول الى بيانات المستخدمين في جميع
انحاء العالم من جانبه رد تيك توك على
المطالب الامريكيه متحدث باسم المنصه
الصينيه قال ان بيع الاسهم لن يحل مشاكل
الامن القومي المتصوره فالطريقه الافضل
لمعالجه هذه المخاوف هي الشفافيه وحمايه
من داخل الولايات المتحده لانظمه وبيانات
المستخدمين الامريكيين يقول المتحدث باسم
تيك توك
دائره الحرب تتسع اكثر مع مرور الايام
المملكه المتحده هي الاخرى اعلنت حظرا
فوريا للتطبيق الصيني على الاجهزه
الحكوميه بسبب مخاوف متعلقه بالامن ايضا
وكذلك فعلت وقبل دول كثيره اخرى ليستمر
مسلسل تيك توك بحلقات كثيره ومتداخله بلال
البجداني العربيه